Quick reminder, we had a payment rail
issue with our provider and so we had to
extend the coupon code to Friday, this
Friday, September 4th. They say the
problem has been solved. We could see
the problem solved, which is great, but
we wanted to apologize for that. We did
have to extend the coupon code for the
Meet Kevin membership. Uh, and remember,
you can still bundle. Last chance here
to bundle and get that lifetime access
for Reinvest AI. If you're a course
member, you could also email us at
staffmeke.com, get a bundle code and
lock in that lifetime access before it
goes away. You'll keep it, but everybody
else will have to pay a subscription
price to get it going for ADP.
Employment numbers came out this
morning. They missed expectations. But
what's happening with the labor market
at a snapshot today, I think matters
less than what's happening with the
labor market very broadly because there
is an underlying risk occurring in the
labor market that is making the labor
market seem stronger than it is. And
ironically, the more the labor market
moves in this particular direction, the
more fragile we actually become. In
other words, the more what's currently
happening keeps happening, the more
dangerous the labor market actually
becomes. And look, today, you know, for
example, we heard a news that Uber is
laying off 10% of its staff. Okay, some
of this is mostly because Uber hasn't
really had layoffs since postco.
Obviously, there was a surge of hiring
postcoid and some companies are still
filled up to the point where they're a
little overloaded with employees and so
some of the trimming is is normal and
you know that can always obviously seem
insensitive to to humans and it's like
oh let's cut labor to increase profits
but that's going to happen and so we're
just observing that from the outside.
What's more interesting to me uh once we
get we'll go through the ADP data here.
What's more interesting to me is how uh
if you combine the fragility that's
actually building in the labor market
right now with potentially higher
interest rates, that's where we really
want to keep a close eye on what's
happening. This one data point. So,
we'll hit that in just a moment. Uh for
now though, let's go to the uh Meet
Kevin app. So, we're going to go to
app.mmekevin.com
and let's pull some of these charts that
we've got here. Uh Remember, you can
download uh the the app on your phone
for free at meetke.com or um uh well,
sorry, download the app for free in the
Apple or Android app store. Just type in
Meet Kevin. Okay, so what do we have
here? These are the ADP estimates versus
reality for the information we got
today. So you can see the average and
median estimate was right around 57,000.
Deutsche Bank thought we were going to
come in at 65,000. What's interesting is
their estimate isn't even on here.
Sometimes you get estimates like they've
got what do we got? They got 29
estimates here. Sometimes banks have
their own. They don't even make it into
these surveys. So know that there are
probably more that are likely to
distribute along a similar pattern here.
You got someone who's nuts thinking that
the labor market's going to send ADP up
at a weekly rate of like 30,000 a week.
We have not seen weekly rates of gains
in employment of 30,000 a week since
March and April. And there's a potential
reason for that we'll touch on. Um, but
you could actually track the weekly data
every Tuesday and you know we're at like
8 to 10,000. And so we actually ended up
getting 38,000 as a read this morning
which is in my opinion relatively
consistent with that 8 to 10,000 move.
So I don't think this is really that big
of a deal. The ADP report you've got a
little bit of a mix here where AP
themselves say hey we're sort of a
choppy environment. It used to be more
predictable to kind of see what's going
on with the labor market. Things are a
little weird right now. Yeah, you've got
this AI construction boom. People are
still spending summer vacations,
leisure, hospitality. The wealth effect
is in full effect. Um, but you still got
the slowest pace of job creation since
January. Some of that should be offset
though by the slowest pace of job
creation since January. I think one of
the easiest things to do here is just do
a quick little whiteboard explanation
because it's really important when
you're looking at the labor market. You
almost have to adjust away the first
quarter. We uh we had a really slow
labor market going into the year. Uh and
then in February, we started hearing
about, oh no, we're going to war with
Iran. And what actually happened is a
lot of manufacturers, if you study the
weekly ISM or S&P manufacturing reports,
you could see it happening. A lot of the
manufacturers, and they say it bluntly,
were hiring to start building stock
assuming that prices would rise. So,
there was basically this, you know,
boogeyman of inflation that companies
expected and they're like, well, we may
as well build supply now, build up
inventories, hire a bunch of people. So
you saw this boom in hiring really
between March and May that kind of gave
this I would almost call it a false
impression that the labor market was on
fire and really really booming. It
actually aligned with all-time highs in
the NASDAQ before the SpaceX sucking in
June, right? Uh and so we've kind of
seen this like what feels like a
collapse since then, but it's
stabilized. It's stabilized at around
10k jobs per week. That's what we've
seen on the BLS data. That's what we've
seen on the ADP data. And in fairness,
we do have new BLS data coming out on
Friday. So, I would say take the
information that we have here and and
sort of use it to prepare for Friday so
you know what single number to really
pay attention to. It's not really the
headline number that I'm worried about.
And it could be really premature
uh to even talk about this, but when it
hits, it's going to suck. Um the BLS
forecast, just so we could get it out of
the way, we are looking for 55,000 jobs
on non-farm payroll, uh 50 on private
payroll. Even if we get anywhere close
to that, you know, 30 40, it's going to
be relatively consistent with this
thesis here. Uh and the good news is
this is still above that zero line where
we're shrinking. So we still have some
growth happening. There's a lot of
rejiggering happening in the labor
market, of course. The big problem that
we have though uh is something that
actually makes us more sensitive to
interest rate hikes in the future.
Interest rate hikes make things more
expensive. We know that. But they also
mean people who don't have a job might
end up getting convinced that ah crap,
we're going to have to jump back to work
sometime soon. That issue relates to the
labor force participation rate. And
we've talked quite a bit about this, but
I want you to see how extreme it's
getting. This chart right here, this
lower one, the labor force participation
rate indicates while these percentage
changes are very, very small, they're
actually a big deal because you're
applying those percentages to 157
million people. So when you get a you
know10% so like a 10 basis point move,
0.1% move, you're talking about lots of
people, right? Uh so you know every
percent is one and a half million. Uh
every 0.1% is 150,000 people. It's like
two Taylor Swift stadiums, right? A lot
of freaking people.
Labor force participation rate has
really collapsed this year. It was
already falling in 2025
and our ICE rates kind of got us a
little temporary blow over here in the
middle of 2025 maybe post tariffs or
whatever. But it has fallen off a cliff
relative to the stability that we had in
2023 and 2024 on the participation rate
which is ironic because in 2023 and 2024
we were contending with this. These are
the number of uh uh payrolls right here.
This was before Trump. Look right here
where this mouse is. You see this
collapse in payrolls right here? Right
there where we went to basically zero uh
on jobs right there. That's where people
are like, "Oh, Jerome Powell cut
interest rates because of the election."
Remember September of 2024? He cuts 50
basis points and be like that a-hole
just wants to try to get Biden in or you
know Kamla in at the time, right? And
the reality was, and I'm not saying
there's not a political bias, okay? I
personally think Kevin Worsh is a hack
and, you know, he's going to do whatever
he can to to shield the Donald Trump.
So, don't get me wrong, I've got
political jade as well. I just think
looking at the data then, maybe there
was 10% political rationale. I think 90%
of it was because of that collapse in
the labor market we saw. And we were
watching, we're like, "Holy smokes, this
is not good." And then, of course, you
had the Japanese carry trade. uh you
know that was the icing on the cake. We
had a recovery after that though just
like this magical recovery. I thought
some of it could have been because of
enthusiasm around actually Trump winning
the election. Um it could have been data
collection. Who knows, right? But the
point is all of that drama that happened
in 2024. Sorry to make you relive that
drama. All of that drama
did not affect the labor force
participation rate. Okay. labor force
participation rate has literally
collapsed since then. And here's what
you need to know about a low labor force
participation rate. It creates a fake
floor of glass
under the unemployment rate. And this is
the nasty part that doesn't make sense
to a lot of folks because, you know,
you've got even the Federal Reserve.
They're like, "Oh, unemployment's fine.
Look how stable the unemployment rate
is. Everything's fine. There's nothing
to worry about." You get that talk all
the freaking time. You know the employ
unemployment rate. Oh, it's 4.1. It's
4.2%. You know, whatever. Somewhere in
this range somewhere between 4.1 to 4.3.
That's freaking low. People like, oh,
that's maximum employment, whatever. But
what happens with the math is that every
time the participation rate goes down,
you actually lower the unemployment rate
and you could actually see a decline in
the participation rate. that accelerates
faster than the job loss you're seeing.
So in other words, you could literally
see job loss skyrocketing. If the
participation rate is falling faster,
job loss can go up and the unemployment
rate can go down. So in other words, you
could literally have the labor market
collapsing from a a labor force point of
view in terms of actual job loss. uh how
many people are losing their jobs. But
the participation rate or the way the
analysts, you know, tell you uh what
percentage of people are actually
involved and actively looking for a job,
they're not discouraged workers. Uh you
know, they haven't given up because they
can't find a job with their skills or
they haven't retired early or whatever.
Uh or they're employed part-time and
they wish they could be working
full-time, right? All those metrics go
into this. They tell you ah labor force
participation rate is plummeting. the
more it plummets, the more it actually
hides this. So the market doesn't see
job losses skyrocketing. It only sees
the unemployment rate going down. That's
all it sees. But the problem is not that
this is going down. The real problem,
and this is the scary part, is when
interest rates go up and the Fed hikes,
you make life more expensive and you
drive people who otherwise may have
given up trying to look for work, you
potentially drive them back into the
labor market. Now, if you have an
increasing labor force participation
rate or a normalization of the labor
force participation rate and you have
those hidden job losses, you now have
two forces that push up the unemployment
rate. Like if you had stable jobs, no
job losses, no job creation, and the
participation rate went up, the
unemployment rate would shoot up. If you
have participation rate going up and you
have job losses, this will go up even
faster and rate hikes make this even
more likely. And so that's the fragile
nature of the labor market because if
the labor market all of a sudden imagine
we get the labor force participation
rate normalizes, right? And we go back
to a participation rate that is, you
know, 62.4%.
So now add 1% of people that are now
deemed to be participating. That's one
and a half million. Just to pick numbers
here for a moment, okay? You go back to
a normalized labor force participation
rate. That's 1.5 million more people
need to have gotten a job. If we only
got if we only added a 100,000 jobs that
month, uh so plus this, then we have now
net
lost 1.4 4 million jobs per the
statistical changes which all of a
sudden takes this unemployment rate and
possibly jacks it up a whole percent.
And so you could instantly go from 4.1%
to 5.1 and then you start getting talk
about the Claudia Som rule is getting
triggered. Oh my gosh, what's happening?
market sells off and then you
potentially get this self-fulfilling
uh you know capex slowdown, artificial
intelligence spend slowdown because
people are like oh my gosh labor
market's collapsing we must be going
into a recession and it all comes simply
because of that one stupid line. Now I'm
not saying that's what's going to
happen. This number could keep going
down. They could also be rigging that
number down. And you know that's also
kind of weird, right? They that this
idea that this number could be getting
just rigged down. But what you need to
know is the more this number goes down,
the more we're pulling on a rubber band.
Simple analogy, the more labor force
participation goes down, the more we're
pulling on this rubber band, and
eventually it's going to snap.
Eventually, it's going to snap back to
normal. Uh, and so these discouraged
people or the people who gave up or
whatever, they end up coming back to
work or the statistics, the way they
they analyze it, the numbers, whatever,
change. That's a big risk for the
economy right now. and and and I I think
not a lot of people are paying attention
to that. Let's look at the rest some
some of the other numbers on uh the the
labor market though because you know and
and the overall economy overall if we
look at earnings for companies they are
doing well
you've got the S&P 500 Xtech seeing
growth growth outside of technology
still at 23% here at the end of 2026
this is really good so you know people
say oh but Kevin you know growth rates
are so good at companies yes they are
but but both can be true growth rates
could excellent at companies, but they
could also be firing people at the same
time or hiring fewer people. What what
I've seen in earnings calls, and I see
this at other businesses as well, but
what I see is this, you know, wow,
there's this AI revolution. Let's hire
some people. Let's acquire companies to
help us with artificial intelligence.
Let's get our own AI going. At some
point, that investment in the human
capital stops. Got the AI team. You
don't have to hire anymore. So, you get
sort of a temporary upfront boom. What
happens when you start cutting? That
sort of adds to this problem. But
ironically, even if that happens,
company profits can continue to grow.
And that's the big thing here. Now, you
look at the S&P 500 year-over-year
growth rates for earnings per share.
We're looking at 44% here as an estimate
for the last quarter. That's great.
It means companies are making more money
from artificial intelligence, but that
doesn't mean uh labor force
participation isn't going to skyrocket
and normalize. Here's another uh thing
to look at in terms of a weakening labor
market. Average hourly earnings,
year-over-year wage growth. If worker
wages were a corporation, I would argue
workers have on net lower pricing power.
In other words, the rate of change in
people's ability to demand more money
for their services, for their human
capital has plummeted. We've gone from
somewhere around uh getting average
hourly wage growth of around five four
and a half% per year down to 3.1%. That
actually means uh uh I'd have to double
check if these are real numbers. These
might already be the real numbers, but I
was going to say if they're not the real
numbers, if these are just nominal wage
growth numbers, you're actually losing
money every year to inflation. You know,
your wages are now net negative. Should
have checked that before. I didn't.
Sorry. But anyway, the trend doesn't
matter, right? If I pull 4% off
inflation off of this and 4% on
inflation off of this or 3% whatever
level you want to use, uh the whole bar
is just going to move down close to
zero. So point is worker pricing power
still trending down. All of that to me
suggests we're in a weird place in the
economy where corporations can boom in
profits, corporations can boom on
investment spending. At the same time,
you could be squeezing people out of the
labor market that are okay for now.
But eventually, if these folks, the same
percentage of people who are usually in
the labor market come back because rates
got higher, corporations are still
getting richer, but the people aren't
getting richer because wage growth is
down. An easy way to think about this is
like a two family household, two worker
household, mom and a dad or whatever.
One person, you know, I'm just going to
stay home. I'll go study or whatever.
You get squeezed by higher interest
rates. Eventually, you might have to go
back to the labor force.
That happening on scale is exactly what
sort of turns the whistle, if that's
even the right trade.
On Friday, we will have a BLS jobs data.
The only number I really care about is
that labor force participation rate. I
don't think it'll skyrocket anytime
soon, but when it does, when it does,
that is your bat signal that winter is
coming.
Okay, cool. So that gives us why not
advertise these things that you told us
here? I feel like nobody else knows
about this.
>> We'll we'll try a little advertising and
see how it goes.
>> Congratulations, man. You have done so
much. People love you. People look up to
you.
>> Kevin Praath there, financial analyst
and YouTuber. Meet Kevin. Always great
to get your take.